the pace of change
is now going to accelerate like a new
tesla because i can tell you as a former
motoring correspondent evs may not
burble like sucking doves and they may
not have that
that you love but they have so much
torque that they move off the lights
faster than a ferrari and
so with safer streets uh with great
local schools uh with fantastic uh
broadband
um
ah
forgive me
forgive me
forgive me
people will have the confidence to stay
nearer the place they grew up to start
business and business uh will have the
confidence
to invest hands up anybody's been to pep
a big world
not enough
i was well i was fact i was a bit hazy
what i would find at peppa pig world uh
but i loved it and peppa pig world is is
very much my kind of place
uh it it
is it has uh
a uh very safe streets
uh
discipline in schools uh
heavy emphasis on new mass transit
systems i noticed uh even if they're a
bit stereotypical about about daddy pig
uh but the real lesson for me going to
peppa pig world and i'm surprised you
haven't seen that
uh was about the power of uk creativity
uh who would have believed uh tony that
a pig that looks like a hair dryer uh or
or possibly a well a sort of picasso
like hair dryer uh in your speech to the
cbi
you lost your notes you lost your place
you went off on a tangent about peppa
pig frankly is everything okay
i think that
i think that people uh got the vast
majority of the
the points i wanted to make and i
thought i thought it went over well
thank you thank you
you